[ __ ] désolé ma puce ma femme va
réveiller pour vos billets n'y a pas
d'erreur possible car ils ont bien été
utilisés par madame blanc car moi j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'à se doute de
quelque chose c'est la première fois que
vous venez encore la suite nuptiale
enfants fait week-end duo c'est bien ça
alors j'ai toujours eu envie de faire ça
je m'inquiète pas qui la connaît maman
alors qu'il est doit être au lit avec
une tisane et je n'ai pas l'impression
qu'à boire une tisane
[Musique]
il faut trouver là haut
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé je me
suis réveillé et respirer que je suis
désolé on arrive tout en cellule de
dégrisement garde à vue la totale bien
voilà c'est ma belle fille
alors excusez moi madame mais c'est pas
du tout ce que vous croyez
pour être un fêtard les listes alors
pour assurer ma mère je convaincu de
s'inventer une petite élite
c'est maintenant que l'ami un visage sur
sa belle fille idéale on fait quoi
ça va aller oui très bien attendre qu'un
pour bien sûr pas très bien mais c'est
très bien qu'on va plus je te connais je
suis heureuse accepte tu tu être ma
belle fille s'est terminée ce attend le
bus qui devrait passer en juillet
pas du tout plu au public dont tu m'as
fait paul aurait plus jamais ça elle a
besoin du soutien de sa famille et sa
famille c'est qu'ils n'ont pas dit non
non c'est vous
[Musique]
elle prépare une soirée pyjama journal
qu il y aura pas de soirée que je marque
ça va tu es bien installé j'ai pas les
mots
[Musique]